why is divorce frowned upon I always
bring it down to one issue in the ummah
is the lack of taqwa and
self-accountability okay from a personal
point of view I'll be honest I will find
it very difficult to marry somebody
who's divorced I'm sorry I'm sorry
please and a lot of mothers think that
their sons are angels that they just
fell through the sky and they are
perfect marrying a divorced woman they
think oh gosh no my son deserves the
best he deserves a princess even if he's
divorced himself he still deserves a
queen the guys even if they're not in
love anymore they're gonna carry on yes
the sisters it seems that when they lose
their romantic attachment and that love
and they start comparing and so on they
will fall out with the Somali Community
like personally myself I've realized
that they don't frown upon divorces I
know now sisters that I mentioned before
who are actually turning to non-muslim
men because they are more accepting of
divorced women can I grow up you're
gonna do the things you're gonna get
married and you're gonna it's like a
status thing as well and it's like if
you are divorced you're bringing shame
upon the family the the daisy
subcontinent culture does frown upon
divorce a lot but I think it's
it's more complex than that because
there's a reason the early stages for a
man it's oh yes amazing for a woman it's
misery Etc on the long run you guys heal
faster sisters you have been divorced
they are most likely to work 10 times
harder to make that marriage last than
anyone else who hasn't hasn't got that
experience
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a southern for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you and the shall be working award click
the link and donate what you can
assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters
and dear friends welcome to another
episode of The Bitter truth I hope you
guys are benefiting from this inshallah
and do us give us your feedback if you
believe that we should improve in
certain aspects whether it may be we are
open inshallah uh before I start and I
want to praise Allah the most merciful
the most trust or Praises glory and
gratitude belong to him we hope that
these sessions that we do
um is the aim is that it helps you guys
at home who's on the verge of divorce
which is going to be our topic today
um or those who are looking to get
married who are married what if it may
be our aim is inshallah to help the
family unit and that we can have Muslims
who are striving to the Hereafter
together inshallah
um so yes so the bit of Truth the email
is here if you want to get in contact
you want to be among the panel like our
honorable sisters our brothers here as
well inshallah please get in contact and
yeah or if you have any questions you
can send it there
in a nutshell
um a lot of people complain I speak fast
but I think I need to slow down let's
introduce our honorable esteemed guest
uh hello the one and only tell us a bit
about yourself please
my name is
um
um what can I say
I'm very smart very intelligent uh can
you stop talking about me and yourself
oh sorry sorry uh no no but I just want
to say honestly all jokes aside
everywhere I go and by far the most
handsome person there but today I feel
very very uh uncomfortable because this
brother here martial law is very very
handsome when I walked in my heart
started beating
honestly like like in today's time I'm
trying to I'm trying to like speak
slowly because I'm starting yeah like
Marshall every time I'm about it
is a very good looking guy so yeah
Marshall thanks for the introduction
brother Gabriel we know you of course
but just a brief introduction of what
you do
um
and I work with rebuilding masculinity
in the um I have a Muslim Alpha Man
course
a little bit me too as well
thank you so yeah
yeah it's a little bit of advertising
there no of course of course of course
how could we not Michelle you're here
for the sake of the ummah doing
something how can we not support it the
link will be there if you want to
inshallah go check it out and shower
bomb sisters and brothers who are
sleeping on the couch maybe time to wake
up and yeah check brother Gabriel
romani's inshallah program what's it
called again what's the malformation
Muslim Alpha men some sisters get scared
when they hear that but we'll contact
later our honorable sisters please um if
you can start just introduce yourself
briefly please
a broadcaster life coach speaker and
work on different channels
um yeah
you're comfortable
I am known as well to be Madina twins
for the brand Martina Paris we designed
and encourage sisters to be back to
modesty the real one the beautiful one
the blessing from Allah and as well I
have a personal pleasure to solve when I
talk about divorce healing marriage
struggle motherhood struggle with all
honesty and encouragement to sisters to
go back to femininity and being very
careful with this all feminism movement
I mean may Allah bless you from the
clothing line to your personal thing to
your uh promoting femininity there's
something that's needed me Allah bless
you inshallah and preserve you and allow
you to carry on inshallah and sister
I am iridine the current American school
as well as great contact content to help
Muslim women understand themselves
better
um to become more self-aware which will
benefit them in becoming closer to Allah
may Allah honorable sister so um just
got a new concept here by the way just
to introduce you
[Music]
uh this is the bitter buzzer so okay
argument said if somebody's saying
something would you disagree with me
from our side by the way and you're like
you know what he's maybe I need to drop
a bit of trivia okay but the moment you
press it I finish my sentence and you've
got one and a half minutes to go in okay
it's very small okay cool yeah so
especially for you because I know you
need it but you're only allowed to use
it once oh yeah because you know you
don't like to get married again so one
is enough for you if I disagree with a
lot of things you say though then you're
gonna have to uh yeah yeah so anyway so
guys today's topic is quite a serious
one
um and
it's the matter of divorce
um divorce is look down upon we've
talked about this on our episode kind of
briefly touched up on uh on it should it
be frowned upon should divorce be
frowned upon and after we discuss that
what is the healing process and also is
there lessons to be learned divorce is
divorce a bad thing is it a horrible
thing is it something that teaches us
something so in a nutshell let's start
off with
why
is divorce frowned upon and then we can
move to Healing from that
um
let's start off with the sisters
let's start off with
just a song
I'm not sure if I'm qualified to speak
about the main causes of divorce not of
course but do you think like divorce is
there I always bring it down to one
issue in the ummah is the lack of taqwa
and self-accountability for the most
part I mean if we have to summarize all
the causes they come we have like 1 000
causes of divorce but I always think
with all honesty is the lack of from
brothers or sisters and the lack of
self-accountability before you were
talking a lot about therapy and I was
expecting to the sisters like we are in
a assisting Society brothers and sisters
are struggling with self-accountability
and is the first step to Healing to
fixing a problem to anything even to
going back to Allah azawajal you have to
first realize that you are in trouble or
you need fixing so for me those for me
are the two main causes of divorce okay
sister Ayah you talked about for example
the Asian community and when it comes to
divorce how is divorce viewed in your
community
um and because you did mention that you
yourself got divorced um so I do know
there is like this you know negativity
like oh you should never get divorced by
all means please so like you said
divorce is a hundred percent frowned
upon it is the most despicable thing a
woman can do and sadly it's always the
woman who is too blameful because I
think
culture is toxic so the year South Asian
culture is very very toxic and we are
told from a very young age our sole
purpose in life is to grow up become
alive turn your house into a home and
raise the children
and therefore when you are unable to do
that for whatever reason not send it to
sister's fault because you know there's
two sides story
um the blame comes down to you like
there is something wrong with you you
are broken you are defected and now
nobody's gonna want you because now
you've got a past you've got a history
you know you've broken one marriage now
people are going to be worried that
you're going to break their homes
and
a lot of mothers think that their sons
are angels that they just fell through
the sky and they are perfect so then
when they think about
marrying a divorced woman they think oh
gosh no my son deserves the best he
deserves a princess even if he's
divorced himself he still deserves a
queen interesting interesting okay bro
any like I was going to press the buzzer
but I well you hold yourself back I'll
use it because you might need it you
might need someone else
there's um
there's there's a few things that I
agree with from what you said
that there are certain cultures that do
frown upon divorce a bit more than
others
um
if you look at a western culture right
Muslims within a western culture
it's still frowned upon but we see a
change in that
that uh assessment like it's not that
frowned upon anymore right and again
we're very influenced by we're you know
there's no
in Bangladesh for example or Pakistan
it's a more homogeneous culture what
does that mean a meaning is more agreed
upon even though there's differences
very homogeneous right and it's quite
heterogeneous in the west meaning
there's a lot of philosophies a lot of
ideologies and the Muslims are
influenced by it there's no way it
doesn't matter what people say in the
end the environment will affect you to
an extent right so
indeed the the Desi subcontinent culture
does frown upon divorce a lot but I
think it's
it's more complex than that because
there's a reason I I can't I understand
the sister she's from that culture I am
married into that culture so I have gone
there seen it understood I lived to an
extent within certain dynamics of that
Society or you know yeah so but I don't
want to make the argument from
experience but I would say that um
there's some good to that because if you
look at the pakistanis the bangladeshis
the Indians of the Desi culture yes they
do have a problem with what I call
cultural Islam
which means that
uh
they make culture
yeah then there's but then there's also
Islamic culture which is inspired from
Islam and definitely within the Pakistan
there are some very very good aspects so
should people just jump into divorce you
find that within that culture they do
try to push it as far as possible are
they going to make the dolm in that well
yeah there is a lot of examples of porn
but is that necessarily a bad thing if
they are
as the sister said like you're expected
as a woman to become a good wife
obedient wife to build a good house
those are good things they are good
things why are they negative things they
are good things what becomes toxic is
when people don't see where the truth is
so for example a lot of people come to
me with this question
but just because and we just spoke about
in-laws and I forgot to mention this
but those say
just because the elders or my father or
my mother you know Elders the concept of
the others is there in the
does that necessarily make them right so
they kind of make they equate being
right with the position of that person
in the family if it's the grandfather he
sits at the front of the table usually
yeah whatever he's the wise man he might
not even know
right but whatever he does or whatever
he says goes that's where the dorm comes
in right and you know the process like
um
and
he had the answer you know but he said I
was shy too because of the people also
have the big sahaba right he said no
that would have made me but I would be
proud of you if you just spoken the
truth but they have knowledge that's the
difference it's the knowledge and the
truth right it's not about who you are
because there is respect for the elders
yeah but sometimes that becomes toxic if
we take that over the truth I would say
that's where the problem is so is the
culture itself toxic I don't think so
there's a lot of great things in the
subcontinent culture yeah it's such as
the you know family how United they are
yes the fact that they're going to
really sacrifice for each other as
opposed to Western culture the smallest
thing man the smallest thing divorce yes
divorce yes divorce divorce divorce
right away right hola hola hola hola
right three to locks in one if you
follow the opinion right you're finished
yeah but you see in that culture that's
not gonna fly that much right because
people are gonna interfere there's
certain
appearances that you have to maintain
which is good and bad at the same time I
think we need to be very very specific
okay so look at that interesting man I
bless you where do we draw the line
because the thing is it's like I have
like I've seen like with the Asian
Community Etc this concept with the
Somali Community like personally myself
I've realized that they don't frown upon
divorces like they don't like this it's
like it's calm like you're married a
divorcee you don't see that with the
Somali Community for what I've seen like
with the Asians I have seen it you're
from Iraq
from your culture
okay so from your culture is it frowned
upon divorces like especially a
divorcement because it's a reality let's
be real here yeah when a woman is
divorced it's not the same when it's a
man is divorce yeah okay and in Islam
they're both divorce divorce is a
divorce yeah but divorce is a divorcee
but the thing is when it comes to
um not following Islam and following
your culture as if like like I said the
woman becomes like tarnished and I'm
like where does this come from
something about what you just said that
the the push that our culture gives us
can be beneficial it's a bit like say
someone criticizes you it's up to you
how you want to take it either it can
get really offended or you can act one
it so even though that is good
our culture doesn't see like that and
they don't portray like that because
when you are young
your parents I mean I'm Pakistani and so
I'm going to talk on my culture they
want you to live your life according to
their terms so you're going to grow up
you're going to do all those things
you're going to get married and you're
gonna it's like a status thing as well
and it's like if you are divorced you're
bringing shame up on the family exactly
so I agree to that even yeah
I just want to add the fact that a very
often women are double victim they are
victim from I'm talking about the one
that been left abandoned victim of
Oppression they already victims of
whatever traumatic event they had to go
through but then this victim um an
accusation constant blame is like she's
even guilty for being a victim of a
situation
I'm not I'm not talking about the one
that decided to leave family for
whatever reason that seems superficial
I'm not talking about this new trend I'm
talking about real sisters that went
through oppression that have been left
abandoned by husbands that think that
maybe could grab someone else and just
leave his wife and kids I'm talking
about those because divorces have
different reasons different situation
I'm talking about sisters that are clear
victims because everyone wants to jump
on the wagon and all sisters are victims
and no sometimes sisters need to take
accountability sometimes they are
responsible for the difference
they are divorcing for the wrong reasons
but sometimes and they and they initiate
it like statistics show that and it's
really understand it's in the nature but
even statistics show that rather than
problem solve they will like leave the
marriage rather than trying to I am not
saying that is all the case of sisters
it's very important we represent the
real victims because Allah has gave a
strength um a position to the husband
rightfully so and sometimes it's abused
it's very interesting you know that
because I was reading Imam Portugues of
Syria so basically you know there's a
consequence we deal with the non-muslims
ETC like oh look at your religion it's
misogynist because a man can give talaq
about a woman can't if you look into the
see it's very interesting what he says
is that the Arabian in the Arabian
Peninsula that Arab men used to abuse
their wives by for example I divorce you
yeah she goes and she says okay no
problem I want to move on nope I'll take
you back and there was no limit to it
and Allah set it to free talaqs to keep
the man in check because he knows and
check this out this is how beautiful
Islam is if you look at here free talaks
is to keep the man in check meaning
you can't stop it from moving on you've
got free if you can't control yourself
and your emotionally Let It Be guess
what when you give the fertile what is a
ruling she has to go after the period
depends she she needs to go get married
again
obviously you married and then divorce
now for a man
this is very interesting psychological
yeah because for a man to Envision his
wife or somebody else so for him if he's
given that last talaq yeah no let's not
let's not let's because other than they
say two types of people don't learn the
one who's arrogant the one is shy so
we're here to benefit people inshallah I
know it might be a big thing but let's
be real here so for a man he's thinking
if I'm giving this last tala what it
means is the following my wife is Haram
for me and she will have to be with
another man there's nothing but
yeah so that is put in place so he keeps
the management even though we can say
sister yes the initiate divorce but a
real man talking about the alpha course
which people need to sign up to that you
should be a leader in control and be
like hold on a second if she's emotional
I don't need to be emotional okay come
on man be a real man so in that aspect
it's very important for us to understand
that that like who said our sisters can
be you know should be taking the
accountability as well but yeah you know
actually I just wanted to put that out
there because it's a big misconception
and that tala is a responsibility you
know
but I just wanna I just was talking
about the double shaming of the woman
okay let's go because in your culture
what's your perspective should a woman
be shamed when it comes to being
divorced uh would you would you at the
topic is not what you're married divorcy
but it's in your culture is it frowned
upon so
um honestly I I'm not I'm not like too
well educated in in like my culture
personally but how is it it's not about
my education when you're growing up no I
just I I personally think um you asked
earlier why is divorce frowned upon I
don't think it's frowned upon because if
something that's happening so frequently
how can it be frowned upon
I want to marry a sister she's divorcy
yeah bro yeah in the Asian Community bro
they'll say hell no she she's a um yeah
she's finished the question is Marion
someone does yes like like the divorce
found out yeah yeah wait it's divorce
around the point or is marrying someone
that's divorced frowned upon what's your
questions yeah yeah both sorry man yeah
yeah that's two different questions okay
they go with it
for the second one so marry someone
who's yes would you would you uh marry
someone's friend okay cool from a
personal point of view personal and
cultural okay I can't oh oh okay from a
personal point of view I'll be honest I
will find it very difficult to marry
somebody who's divorced I'm sorry I'm
sorry please I'm just waiting for
someone to press the button no no no no
no yeah
me personally is because most men will
be like that yeah it's normally and the
main reason is the main reason why is
the main reason okay the main reason is
is because
all right guys calm down basically what
what it is is I will find it very very
hard I will find it very very hard to be
with somebody knowing that she's been of
another man
now before any of you try to say
Obviously security that's that's that's
our third topic by the way we're going
to come to that but we're talking about
somebody who's been married
honorably married I think so yeah
it's very important yeah yeah it doesn't
matter marriages
even if they've been married or whatever
just knowing that she's been with
another man just like kind of makes me
feel sorry
okay some of the sisters
so different cultures raise different
men different mothers for men okay and
some of the men are raised by their
mothers and we call them mama's boy
these guys will reflect a certain
insecurity as they are when they grow up
they're adults
um certain cultures again
um will have it more than others and
what happens with that yes if you want
to you press the button off the finishes
it's okay finish your point first that's
a precise point when he said like there
will be mommy boys and they will reflect
in Securities I know Sons some Single
mother's family that actually grown very
mature early age and took the father's
place so they are developing skills
compared to maybe other sons in a normal
family that's not what I'm saying though
I'm saying that mothers have trained
them to be so dependent
cultures
where there's a merit you're talking
about mother and father
raising a boy the mother herself now I
didn't say a single mother okay she's
within a married environment okay she'll
Raise a Man
that is extremely weak and insecure and
those insecurities will lead to
um the way they think about women be it
when they marry them whether this woman
is a virgin or previously married and so
on so other cultures will be a bit
different there's two types of
insecurities there's rational
insecurities such as for example a woman
shows a predisposition to being very
hypersexual very loose and so on but
then the man is going to obviously be
insecure about that and then there's
insecurities that are not really
grounded it's basically they reflect
your own mistakes and problems right
such as being raised being very insecure
always very dependent on a woman very
close to your mother I mean for God's
sakes I had clients to still sleep in
their mother's bed when they don't feel
good okay of course the wives like crazy
I'm sorry I'm but no no
how do you react right so the way you
reacted so bro this this so this if you
look at for example the Arab culture
Mary previously married women yes yes
was the process of an insecure man nope
it was very secure right meaning that he
knew that okay I know who I am I'm gonna
marry this woman yeah she's had another
man before but
I know why not others let's say people
say well he was a prophet saws okay so
that is true other sahaba right did they
said they're like oh man I don't know
right so today
21st century man yeah there will think
that twice tries four five ten times why
before because this was one because the
truth has insecurities yeah and we it's
hard to tell which one is it so sisters
if you're watching this please disclaim
you know what say there was true please
listen to him with an open mind okay
he's trying to make you understand how
as men where we are coming from please
where nobody's attacking you please
understand Us carry on I have to I'm so
sorry no problem so men will have as I
said two types of insecurities yeah and
it's hard to differentiate which one is
it am I insecure because of myself
because of how I look
most guys have come to us those same
hand but how can someone have touched my
wife what if he sorry touched her better
than I did that's a huge problem for a
man right
um in the back of their mind they cannot
conceptualize that someone has
been with his wife or with this woman
before it's very very difficult I've
tested this in Birmingham University for
example I had a huge audience right
of course together say guys will you
marry a woman who's had a past has made
Toba and she's now practicing wearing a
cup I said all the guys together one two
three no I said sisters will you marry a
guy who has had a past but has made
tobus practina one two three they all
said yes so it's insecurities we do
agree with guys we're more insecure
was it insecure two things as I said
there's rationalist insecurities which
mean yes they see something so let's say
This Woman's been married right before
yeah she will say something she'll
behave in a certain way that causes him
to say yeah I'm not very happy with this
I am insecure because she said certain
things women can say one sentence one
sentence and surely masculate you and
wow wow what's the guy going to say to a
woman I mean he might say something will
cause insecurities oh yeah he can
destroy her femininity as well yeah but
but maybe looks wise maybe on the looks
more it will okay different matters I
agree with that it's interesting but but
so that's the Russian secret like for
example she spends a lot of time outside
of the house or with her friends or
she's asking for I don't know she's
still in touch with uh her ex for
example straight straight
divorce happens as well if the woman is
divorced and massage is praying fasting
or you know proper hijab she's there's
nothing there but the guy is like super
obsessed you know where have you been
what are you doing always calling every
two minutes you know there's guys who
can't go to work man yeah they want to
work they call me they're like brother
know I think my wife you know the
internet that isn't it that is an
insecurity one guy who disconnects the
internet yes and that's that's a
self-fulfilled prophecy where if they
carry you on they're going to destroy
their marriage it's interesting you know
so the woman's gonna look at him like
what's wrong with this boy you know it
literally and it causes a lot of
problems I think he'll put a woman off
if a man is behaving in that manner
because he shows no security but deep
inside the Creator is that that's going
to be our next topic as well uh but yeah
it was um yes please sister for him yes
yeah I think I agree with everything
you're saying it obviously and don't
forget what he said that he said that he
would not marry a divorce yeah so I'm
not saying I'm not saying what I said
was right I'm just saying
I'm not saying I'm right or wrong but
I'm just saying I'm trying to say that
you're answering no no it's just that
it's hard to differentiate it's hard to
tell like what is it is this insecurity
I wouldn't call it security I think it's
the thing I wouldn't say I want to say
I'm insecure
um I would say it's just like normal
no no no no no no no no no no no no
manuscript
our next topic yeah is the issue is here
is that somebody who was married before
and somebody who may have committed a
sin
um even though I just want to give some
disclaimers here because there's people
watching you and we don't want to make
them go lose hope yet they might be a
sister who may have committed a sin yeah
and the thing is that person might be a
better person than many sisters out
there that haven't let's make that very
clear because we don't want to be like
because many people watching people come
from they've come new to Islam whatever
it may be even if they would have maybe
yeah so we want to make it clear we are
not making you feel like you are
worthless no because Allah says in the
Quran that a person who fornicates would
only want to be with a person who
fornicates the scholars say that this
doesn't necessarily mean that the person
is a virgin meaning that you might have
a sister or a brother that may have
committed sin and they repented and they
could come and say I want a virgin and
it's the hak to want that so just to
understand but just to make something
clear there are consequences which is
going to be our next topic is the
consequences the same of a woman having
this many sexual partners and a man no
it's not it is far worse for a woman but
that's a different topic let's stick to
this topic inshallah or was it says
something sorry
um well I I do think that um at the end
of the day a lot of Muslim men would not
marry
um a divorcee whether it's for culture
whether it's for on personal reasons
whether security or not security because
they just have this image from a very
young age or generational sort of ways
of thinking that it you know it's not
really for them and they do degrade
women who are actually divorced so
that's what it is as much as they don't
want to admit it they do feel that and
they rather choose somebody who has not
been in that way but maybe somebody who
was actually married and divorced
themselves before may have an experience
to show that actually no I understand
where she's coming from
and if these things can happen so that
could also be a reason because maybe
young men who've never been you know
married before they're not going to
choose that and you know that's what you
know happens most of the time but I do
feel that as much as our religion and
Dean teaches us in this particular way
our culture is really letting us down
because I know now sisters that I
mentioned before who are actually
turning to non-muslim men because they
are more accepting of divorced women and
that's really a problem
regardless of it being working well I
can and and it's Haram it's it's um
but even still they might just convert
them for the names
that's what I'm trying to say but you
know they're just doing it as it is
a good point to mention here when it
comes to this idea of uh previously
married women or women have had sexual
partners
um why do we put them in the same
category I'm really sure which
categories
yeah yeah I agree I agree with you this
honorable relationship hello hello okay
okay meaning in marriage
see obviously there's something that's
going on on in our society that is very
common in the Muslim social media Circle
The Red Pill yeah right a lot of men
young men consume the red pill they
watch this content but that's all they
talk about is about previous sexual
partners the sexual double standard and
so on and yes there's a lot of Truth in
some of the signs that they quote from
sociology and anthropology and all those
studies right but
if you look at their approach and their
philosophy yeah they usually will look
down upon a woman who's had a previous
marriage they talk about pair bonding
they talk about the alpha body counts
they're talking about body counts on
there's some truth there is some trust
to the fifth
like the man is not like the woman
there's a totally taller and we'll talk
about that but it becomes a black or
white thing right and there's so many
nuances again when we go back to the
Quran Sunnah
you find that okay well
what about the sahab who are the best
like how come they did it what was what
was there that they were able to do
okay that they were able to overcome
this well they would live in a different
ways a whole different world because now
you're dealing with some math stuff but
they see that's what I'm trying to say
though is that you can go this or that
you need to analyze I agree with there's
a lot of sisters
who have had certain paths yeah and
they're not good
but they're it's very clear that they're
not good and then there's a lot of
sisters who have had what had marriages
before
and they're good right maybe a sister
who's been divorced
she'll recognize the goodness in you
because of the problems I shared in the
passage she's a good match like man you
are so compared to what I've had before
thank you and this is where we're going
to be our next stop is going to be about
the divorce but before we come to that
that's the healing bit and the divorce
the benefits like there's benefits that
come out divorce as well no just the
benefit of marrying sisters and I want
to just insist on the point mashallah
that our brother here mentioned the
really big denture we have sisters
danger with feminism but we have the
brothers as well uh danger with the red
pill yes it's not based they are talking
down on women being divorcing and
talking about how can we even compare
something that is Haram then something
that is hello you are talking about the
sisters that went through hellel
relationship the Islamic way she didn't
choose maybe her situation
um she'd been left and now she has to be
insulted by the brothers of her own
Community true true but even an Islamic
perspective yeah there's two angles here
number one a sister or a bro
that a sister who has committed to the
sin before so it's not even marriage in
Islam to bring that sin it's this it's
it's it's we're talking about Islam and
then the second thing aside there's no
sisters I've taken hola five times no no
I I know I know same as someone who's
been divorced once it's not so we need
to look at it that true true but we're
actually taking Paula so much 100 but
what I'm saying yes Partners exactly but
just so just so because people who are
watching they don't lose hope like and I
just need to touch them because there
might be people who have sinned and
they're like I don't deserve anything
look look we're not saying that we're
saying you're repented you're a new
person Etc we'll come to the Dynamics of
how it impacts a woman more than a man
but yeah like like you said for example
when it comes to issue divorce like me
personally when it came to my seeking
marriage yeah
um there was like I've mentioned this
before there was two sisters who both
were single mothers and well I I wasn't
married before I wasn't saying all this
this woman this is my second wife no I
was just saying for example that I was
looking to get married I got to know
both of them yeah and it didn't work out
yeah not for oh she was assuming
and I had no problem like to me it was
like okay three kids might be too much
for me two kids okay to me personally
yeah but the point is this I had no
problem as long as they're practicing
there are certain qualities that I look
for bro I had no issue with them being
divorced or not but like I said before I
was saying with the Asian Community bro
it's Madness
press the button no no one's pressing it
press that button please no no just
press this I already get one chance I
don't do that okay I'm ready for a good
moment no but like some guys their past
depends on the decision
for example like my past yeah I'm a good
boy
yeah
I'm a diamond he's a diamond system
uh so yeah so so someone like me yeah
someone like me who didn't mess around
with girls yeah
um so this that that's probably why my
mind says that
if there was a guy before who was
messing around with girls
and then jumping so it depends on the
possible won't have a problem but in a
slap notice it look for me
I'm very sorry guys
talking about body counts um about
previous
um intimate relationship for sisters why
no one talks about brothers that have
many many past relationship and not very
Halal
because men men who sleep with literally
anything anything
so Allah
90 of women I'm so sorry that's that was
my one yeah we're going off topic our
next topic is does a man judge a woman
divorcee Brothers as well what the next
topic is that does a woman judge a man
by his future and there's a man judge a
Woman by a past that's our next topic
let's not go into that now
hold it for that because that's our next
topic here we're gonna go to let's stick
to the divorces being frowned upon
because that's our next topic we're
gonna all this you're talking about
we're gonna discuss it because
statistics show that it is more
detrimental for a woman
divorces to get married exactly that's
obvious with the fact that why brothers
are not struggling why sisters are not
checking their past and see if there is
a pattern of four five six I'm talking
about between five and ten divorce or
marriages after one divorce you're from
the Lord sorry
okay first of all
I think the biggest issue is yeah I'll
be honest with you the biggest issue in
today's day and age divorce has been
easy divorce is easy getting married is
hard understand so because marriage is
hard
men see it as like I only have one
chance to get married do you understand
that's true not true yeah
martial art like you guys are a bit
older than me so I'm talking about like
my age generation yeah so my generation
my age group their mindset is I really
have one chance to get married like yes
because
no you you and I really respected
mashallah and I don't think
um multiple marriages we we made that
point last time but my question is why
is it
sisters move from the pound after one
divorce and my brother's divorced she's
here to announcement
so the point is as I told you if you use
this you're one and a half minute bro
okay next time
so basically the reason is a lot of men
today like like
18 19 20 25 my age group they're they're
scared of getting married right and they
have many excuses not to get married So
eventually when they get married
they want to go for someone that's not
been married instead of someone that's
been divorced
you go I mean because marriage has been
made so difficult so what's so if
marriage has been made so difficult
what chance do you have in their mindset
of going with someone who's been
divorced before you can go with somebody
which could be better but he is
I just wanted to answer that no no one
can speak you've got one and a half
minutes
um you know sisters who have been
married yeah I've been divorced sorry
sorry sisters you have been divorced
they are most likely to work 10 times
harder to make that marriage last than
anyone else who hasn't hasn't got that
experience
the reason why is because we've gone
through that traumatic experience we
know what it entails we know how to be a
wife or at least partly not how to be a
wife and we will sacrifice more
to make this marriage work to keep him
happy because we know what we did wrong
because we have healed from that your
past experience
I've learned from there we have healed
from that or we know right if I was to
nitpick for example I know this marriage
is not gonna work so she's going to
change that right to make this marriage
work harder
the issue is yes okay you know this as a
as a female but the men of this
generation don't know this that's the
case
they think because of the trauma more
likely to get away from the marriage if
anything goes wrong because all she used
to do that because she's always to blame
because sorry because we've labeled her
broken
because we've blamed her for her
marriage rather than saying okay it
didn't work out that's fine it's 50 50 a
marriage doesn't break because of the
woman it breaks because I'm sorry
sometimes it does yeah sometimes it
breaks because of the woman but what I'm
trying to and I agree with what you say
with a sister that didn't choose the
situation but what I'm trying to
emphasize on is that sometimes sisters
will self-sabotage the next because they
didn't
very different
so the value of the woman and the value
of the men are very different I mean
what I want to go into what we're going
to talk about no but it's true it's true
but it's very different so man a woman's
value is in her Chastity and I don't
mean just by her being chased through
just marriage but it's basically what
she's been through even you know so it
is linked to
so they're just different
the male psychology in the female
psychology is very very different the
man is going to look at the woman who's
been divorced or has gone through a
divorce uh in a way that someone's been
with her they've had some issues some
traumas I'm gonna take her on right now
those problems might come into my
marriage exactly okay look we can't go
okay but because you guys know okay but
can she not say that about the man who's
divorced yeah
like that her mind is is different my
mind is going to is going to take on
more of a chance of you know just kind
of overlooking the man I disagree okay
all right they do I think women women
women have and that's why I'm
encouragement so so to check the past
okay there is not a pattern
I I understand where you're coming from
but women will not yeah okay
I've got a text message I've got text
message from my wife so she's saying why
isn't it frowned upon men
yeah psychology of women is different
they're looking at the divorce they're
willing to risk more to get into their
marriage and to you know kind of like
they'll say well if the guy had a past
um his value
doesn't necessarily decrease in her eyes
I disagree a lot okay interesting let's
listen to this please okay
going back just on on what I've learned
from female psychology they're going to
look at a man with experience especially
in intimacy as not necessarily as
something Halal or whatever but she's
not going to have such a huge problem
with it unless this guy's been some
dirty you know yeah but she's not going
to look at it that way the man is going
to look at the woman in a different way
absolutely she will agree no I agree I
think even personally being divorced
myself I wouldn't want to even go with
somebody who has never been married
before I would choose someone who was
married to understand me because I think
I understand where you're coming from
because you might feel that you know you
take it on somebody who has got things
whether they've healed or not it's not
something that you may be able to handle
the fact that she's come from that right
or wrong as it is this is just human
behavior
this one point that the sister made with
regards to British
see Allah doesn't rule something for no
reason yes okay yes a man will choose a
virgin over a non-virgin but depends
again in the Hadith of of the word the
process him spoke about that that man he
this hobby said but I have like I think
he had sisters he had kids off in the
one who said why didn't you marry
someone so I said then this is better
for you someone who's got more
experience than that but you see when
you make and I'm again I'm not I know
people are going to have an issue but
I'll I'll you know I stick by what I say
I don't care it doesn't matter it's the
bit the truth it is the very truth I'll
take responsibility for what I say I
believe
that collagen is a solution for this
because if a man marries
this guy is why are you so hungry
it's not about that you said I'm hungry
religion is hypersexualized right
because it's always looked at from a
intimacy perspective it's not it's a
huge responsibility a man has so many
more form three times more uh options
are going to hell when he is okay
because he doesn't do it right right
yeah yeah
but it plays a big part yeah of course
unless yeah we we yeah we have the right
from inside
for these sisters who are divorced right
so the guy has had let's say takes his
virgin right then he marries another
wife a second wife who's been divorced
he might find that the wife has been
divorced better than them exactly this
is this is what we need to talk about
yes because we're talking about divorces
are like damaged goods and they
psychology
who's been divorced and divorce is not
just for second marriages
let's say he marries the uh first wife
and I do believe personally that if you
marry your first wife as a divorce
you're even more mature woman it is bad
in the process I married Khadijah yes
and even after her so that yeah thank
you okay
alone
and
you will have an easier time to move on
and maybe you can okay have a second or
third you can still marry a virgin if
that's what you want for men that's like
a trophy thing isn't it it seems but see
those women still have the ability to
marry a good man if she's been divorced
so what she's been divorced okay if your
issue was I need to marry a virgin
because I was a good boy or whatever
okay whatever that means not that I'm
making up yeah I go watch you oh no but
so okay you can still have that if
that's is that the issue that's stopping
you from marrying a divorced woman or a
woman is it that's the issue then you
have a chance you can still do it I
think a mature alpha male can actually
handle a divorced person more than
someone you're trying to say sister
exactly what I said listen listen I'm
very helpful
I'm saying one day I may be in a
situation where then you know what I may
say you know what I'm I may think
differently but right now I just it's
not like an insecure thing it's just
like
difference if that's my wife and I love
her yeah yeah
I can't like just I mean we need to go
past this issue that we have this idea
that okay there is value in virginity no
doubt okay but I'll I'll go based on my
experiences in counseling my my clients
it's been married men who haven't been
married to virgins and they've made
their lives hell yeah because many men
have been married to divorced women and
they've made their life very good right
so you have to vet it's not the wife
she's a good woman you have to make sure
you you test everything do your due
diligence yeah
there's volume virgin I'm not saying
that there isn't because he advised that
I'm not saying there isn't but it
depends that doesn't mean now okay just
like if a woman wears in your car does
that mean she's gonna be a good wife a
lot of brothers make that mistake please
don't don't get me don't get me started
please bro please please baby don't take
us down no no never never know
no no no is that enough or yes yes
no no it's not enough you you mentioned
virginity enough to me yeah
just just just just like a disclaimer as
well look our sisters who observe the
hijab who were the club even those who
are striving to you
let's appreciate the fact that you guys
are out there you have this outside I
can walk don't say Muslim no maybe maybe
I'm one of those guys in the Camden Town
punks yeah they grow their beard yeah no
it's true but you guys are simple you're
carrying that symbol in your head so may
Allah bless and preserve you guys
because it's very important that we are
sacred I have to agree 100 side with
what the brothers say they mean that
it's not because
uh perfect or better wife than some and
I am the first one to explain it on my
account sister soul I do not like the
sacred like responsibility that we have
because we're in a cabin no we are human
beings 100 may Allah guide us and same
perspective same with the brothers with
the phobes and the beards and the hats
two concepts when going back to the
cause of divorce and I'm gonna join uh
our brothers
um sorry
um on a point that I think one of the
main causes we forget to speak about
it and I appreciate that the fact that
he mentioned our Prophet Allah the most
self-confident the more healthiest
example we ever had that didn't feel
insecure with Mary there has never been
an issue with marrying a divorce why
because we go back to the Ayah for the
reason why we choose a woman in the
first place
and yes maybe it is like a tsunachima
especially if you're virgin yourself to
marry a virgin person subham Allah but
Allah tell us to look at what please can
we remind ourselves that no one meant
since before we are talking about all
the reasons
is not lesser than the daku of a virgin
because and I insist on that that's a
divorcey sister it depends on her
healing Journey that's why I always
advise see how she's about on her what
did she learn and even when I took
myself to divorcee Brothers in an
Islamic meeting in and asked them what
did you learn from your previous
marriage I don't mind the fact that the
person is divorcing what our mind is the
journey the lesson the wisdom that he
has understood making sure you don't do
the same mistakes and you know what the
first thing I listen to I look for
accountability self-accountability not
saying my wife did this she was D she
was awful she was horrible like most of
the brothers Brothers what she was
doesn't matter what did you learn about
yourself and divorce I want to talk
about was the most self-reflecting
Journey not about me bashing my ex but
what I've learned about myself my flows
and wallahi this is a blessing from
Allah azzawajal if you are able to sit
in the mirror and say you know what
forget him forget what happened may
Allah guide him Allah forgive and may
Allah better all our situation but is to
be able to look in the mirror and think
what are the things that I can take from
this experience and how can I better
myself and get closer to Allah okay and
this is why I just want to go back to
the importance of that so let's let's go
to now the healing process of divorcing
let's talk about that and like I said I
know many examples as well people that I
know
um sometimes it's that divorce like I
was I know a brother and I was speaking
to him and he said if it wasn't for my
divorce I would have destroyed my
marriage today he goes if it wasn't for
the divorce that I went through I would
have not valued my wife I wouldn't
appreciate her and I would have ruined
it so that divorce that I went through
was the biggest blessing for him number
one you protect him from dinner number
two he had a child number three the
mistakes that he learned there he didn't
apply it here and that's why Allah
sometimes makes you fruit huh you got
remarried yeah remarried yeah they got
remarried so sometimes divorce that
we've looked down upon it's something
that is a blessing but let's bear in
mind when we talk about sahaba's time
the prophet's time the woman The woman
there are not the woman today and the
men that that time is not the men today
we're talking about be careful when you
say that though what do you mean by that
as long as you like okay so there's
probably heavy sisters here the more
experienced they do counseling with you
whatever yeah and uh they qualified I've
I give marriage advice like
I said
you're saying that sometimes I
understand your point yeah but I'm
saying some people might take it in a
wrong way where you're saying sometimes
a divorce can be a good thing which I
agree yeah I'm saying people
think of that and listen to that and
think okay I'm gonna get the voice
we are talking about people that are
already divorced already used it and how
to yes I know I know I know I know but
I'm saying people right now will be
going through a certain situation and
we're here you know what some divorces
are good and then they're thinking about
divorce and they hit it they think you
know what maybe me getting divorce is a
good thing and then and then they end up
getting divorced look like yeah be
careful you need to be careful like
explain the points yeah the aim is very
simple yeah look it's very clear with
our episodes and shows that the whole
point is to build the family unit not
destroy it yeah but what we're seeing is
that for those who are divorced and
they're in Despair and like you know
this that to say you know what it can be
a lesson to be learned and there's many
benefits out of it the fact that it
protected you from Zeno the fact that it
protected you from Zen is a massive
thing bro the one is going to stand in
front of Allah who's committed zinnah
and the one who's going to stand and say
I got married the mountains bro there's
a mountain that number one number two
Learning lesson so we're not saying if
you're on the verge we would go back to
our other episodes that we're going to
talk about this is running show in depth
but let's talk about
you do coaching so please let's start
off with you inshallah and then go to
sister soul and then from there yeah and
also says as well so when couples come
to you how would you help them to heal
after a divorce or if you do that
Okay so
with men and women is different
okay there was a study that was uh
published in 2020 I believe about
committed couples who have fallen out
divorce
and there's a misconception that somehow
guys heal faster so it's not crazy
they're not actually heal slower and
it's more painful we're talking here
about when they're committed we're not
talking about the I think a lot of times
when we look at guys we feel that these
boys they just kind of Jump Around yeah
a woman to woman just move on this one
I'm not like a man who's been in love
with his wife yeah and she's supposedly
in love with him they fall out they have
a divorce who moves on faster who heals
fans the woman is is clear the doubt
about this that's what the that's what
the the study shows yeah
so what I'm trying to say is different
so with women naturally they're gonna
have a faster a wide support group my
friends I agree with you usually when
sisters have a problem pretty much very
fast to go to someone they can have
someone that they can they can cry about
it or to someone they can cuddle with
someone they can get a hug from and so
on men not so much okay so the way we
approach healing for men and for women
is is very very different women would
want to understand
uh what the problem was they wanted to
work on themselves they do blame
themselves a lot of times
it happens a lot so you have to build
with women like it's a bit different you
have to approach and dissect everything
they want to understand for the guys
um they're very hard to open up you it's
very difficult to know like what what is
the issue that was your issue that's one
of the reasons High rates of suicide
amongst men amongst so what I do with
men is I'll focus on them building
themselves their confidence their value
and so on and with women most likely
will have to dissect and go into details
and understanding what's their fault was
there no fault uh you really have to go
into details that's how Okay okay so one
and a half minute yeah I agree and
disagree the way he said like sisters go
through healing or women in general with
the fact that dissecting the guilt
phenomena everything
sisters will completely break down like
a completely breakdown
compared to a man a man can move on
quicker but what I have realized through
my experience myself and through other
sisters that I speak to yeah even though
the the consequences of the divorce will
be more dramatic on the sisters
straight away but in the long run I
found that man's Hill less because they
didn't take that time maybe to take that
healing time to dissect the reason
things maybe they need to work on no
they just move on and it's part of as
well the qualities but there can be a
flow when you go through certain events
like that so I will agree and disagree
but sisters for me or woman in general
they will completely break down 30
seconds but in the long term they will
heal better they will move on and when
they heal they're healed men are never
really met so far a man that really took
the steps through the healing and
sufferization self-accountability so the
damage is in the long term that's why we
need we see many people in Industry that
are houseless and when you speak to them
very often I was very surprised it
started with a woman yes with a divorce
thank you and your time is up for that
sister but it's true because the thing
is when it comes to divorce woman
divorced way before the initiation so a
woman starts the divorce process so when
everyone comes and says my wife my wife
sometimes she's left she's no no no no
one second no no one said by the way you
and I agree
okay at the early stages for a man it's
oh yes amazing for a woman it's misery
Etc on the long run you guys heal faster
and that will be I believe because we're
physically stronger you guys are
psychologically stronger and you can cry
I can't go with my friend and cry I
can't go to hijab and be like oh you
give me or give me one slap yeah come
back to your senses okay come here let
me stop you yeah so the thing is we
can't do that you can open up you can
cry about it and it's therapeutic so
that's the that's the yes that's the
case and only that sometimes for a woman
she pre-plans ahead when she if a
brother comes to me and says my wife
wants to divorce me and I'm talking
about divorce not that oh I'm emotional
no she's like I'm like bro that divorce
like a year and a half ago it's just
she's told you today nope no no no no no
I think women I don't believe their
relationships yes yes
there we go yeah and it's not
necessarily because we want to divorce
him but he is doing something that is
pushing me further and further away no
matter how hard I try to put my hand out
and and yes it does depend on the
situation and the woman itself but for
the most part anyways and I think in
order to heal women are self-sabotaging
if we are left with the child society
and culture we're constantly shame us
they will look down upon us five years
online you want to get married oh she's
divorced oh no we don't want her 10
years down the line still the same thing
so it comes down
it comes down to how strong the sister
is and how willing she is to heal how
willing she is to make her future better
okay I've got about seven minutes on the
shoulder can we just talk more about
let's say healing because so for example
what advice would you give somebody's
divorce a sister or a proper
um and they're like you know what I
don't want to live anymore I've got
nothing to look forward to what's would
you give an advice to the sister who's
watching this who's divorced recently
um it is definitely a grieving process
so basically you need to take time to
understand the steps that you're going
to be going through certain feelings and
emotions and you would be advised to
speak to somebody who can help you
unravel that regardless of how it ended
and who's who is it male or female I
think it really is important that you
know you seek some sort of advice
outside family outside friends so that
you could actually get through the
process a lot more easier and quicker
and it can be quicker if it's done in
the correct manner but I think that
generally women will find it a lot more
heartbreaking and I do feel that as much
as you say that women initiate it
regardless of how independently
financially they are they don't want to
break their homes when they have kids
believe me they really don't and you
know if they are forced to it's under
very extreme circumstances a majority of
Muslim women that I know coaching around
the world as well they really don't want
that because they actually know what you
guys are thinking about a divorced woman
so a lot of the times it is not their
choice and they do not go for it so
let's just get that out of the head as
well because
you just got me back from last episode
yes
no I mean women have to tell take
accountability thank you okay it's not
like that I don't think all the women
they don't want to get divorced there's
women
after divorce and they'll say anyways I
don't know why I've done it
I've just done that shot like doing it I
fell out don't you think for it he's a
good guy he's a great man I regret it
now for the wrong reasons a lot of women
are easily influenced today okay you
have to understand
um
I've had
couples divorcing or training to divorce
like about three weeks ago I had a
sister who in front of me and her
husband three of us online said that
well if I would have known that he has
an issue with my social
media
activity I would have not married him
like I don't really want to be if he
controls me like that I don't want and
I'll say wait who's your social media of
your your husband and I said I'm sorry
if you'll be my wife
he's out you know sorry about that but
like no a lot of sisters they are easily
influenced they it's they have to take
accountability some divorce for no
reason we're talking about just the good
sisters and the good Brothers yes okay I
agree I guess sisters will have they
don't want to break their homes I don't
think anyone wants I don't think any man
wants to bring this up no no okay if
we're talking about that I do agree if
we're talking about just in general
let's people being influenced by Society
by Culture by social media guys will
look at what they'll look at
well she's not as beautiful as the one
that I've seen online
yeah they start looking at that and the
sister will be like well he's not taking
me to Dubai as my friend's taking her
exactly exactly he's not so romantic as
I'm seeing some you know or this people
are influenced and a lot of these
influences are causing
people to fall out they're coming from
Dean that's the problem though that's
the problem
who is coming from today how many people
can say we've had great people are
praying fasting and everything and when
you analyze your divorce you go back to
it it's like well
uh my wife is is not as beautiful as you
know the ones that I've seen I can do
better people as that right yeah and
then the system will be like
to say like yeah but he's not so
romantic as this movie that I've seen or
is is not I don't feel the same
butterflies that I felt at the beginning
of our marriage sisters you have to
understand there is this
um for guys
uh being romantic is there at the
beginning maybe that romantic love I
think Muhammad was talking about right
the importance of love right just in the
previous episode I was going to say
something about that but
guys are still gonna go on
if that romance is not there even in
today's world even today exactly okay
but women today men carry on bro I've
seen this yes
let me let me uh clarify that yeah
today's we're not talking about the
great brother and the great sister who
are religious that you know that that uh
I'm talking about today's social media
let's say gen Z yes okay gen Z after
2000. the guys even if they're not in
love anymore they're gonna carry on yes
the sisters it seems that when they lose
that romantic attachment and that love
and they start comparing and so on they
will fall out they start looking for
other and like I was looking like 2017
for example you know 2017 was the year
that women started cheating on men more
than men cheat on women okay yeah and
they used to man used to cheat more
but it's important but still it's in the
Dynamics no no it's coming
see this is important where is this
stemming from it's important because
let's put it for women what I again what
we hear from sisters is that they lose
they don't feel the passion anymore yeah
they don't feel the love anymore he
doesn't love me anymore he doesn't look
at me the same way uh women are
complaining more right now that men
don't give intimacy I mean pornography
pornography but that's not you know
we're not a different issue about yes
but women are relationships guys used to
be like Oh I'm not getting enough right
now women are saying that he's not this
like the men yes there is and we can
talk about that as well there's a huge
issue so
again the question is is why
um
yeah that's probably another topic
another topic on this one yes just um
at the point with what the brother said
um I have to agree and disagree I find
that men today are following the shahawa
more than our fathers and our
grandfathers our fathers and our
grandfathers may Allah bless them they
used to stay even if the next two girl
young girl was beautiful they would stay
with their wife and kid I found them
they were more resistant to fitna how
I'm talking about the premium they will
preserve the family cell I'm not saying
they were perfect I'm saying that the
preservation in my culture of family
cell we talk about women Masha that were
patient they were like um they had a lot
of Sabbath but we don't talk enough
about our fathers they stayed many of
them not saying all of them many of them
stayed and I want to just add a point
with the fact that thinking about all
that one of the main issues that causing
divorce today is the lack of real
masculinity in men's and the lack of
femininity in women womens are turning
to men but no one talks about the fact
that men are turning into women they
have this passion I want to be loved I
want the next
video
what happens the rise of Andrew Tate and
for example many people like that is we
don't come and say you are you are like
a woman we say how to be a man so yes
you don't hear much of no no because the
fact that they are talking about how to
get your regain your masculinity
is to stay in your marriage fight for
your marriage yes but be a good
protector assistant
who's in that I understand my sister you
said that you said you said that our
fathers you said our father like you
said you like your father would say if
they if they saw another a woman they
were good providers yes sister I
understand 100 but guess what these
sisters today are divorcing their
husbands because he wants to get married
again it's a different topic but I'm
just touching up on it no that's the
majority of kids very simple simple
question yeah um Sister Sister Ayo
please
yeah if you have if you are a good
husband good husband protect the
provider very good Etc he goes and gets
a second wife are you staying in that
marriage please be brutally honest
I will consider it oh you Liars
no sorry sorry
sorry I was in the position once so I
actually did have to consider that okay
okay may Allah bless you you are a very
generous you are very rich sister what
you said with our forefathers we're not
our own fathers right again do you know
whether they they stayed in a marriage I
agree with you
um do we know they didn't cheat no that
means they know they
um to Express their sexuality for the
longest time we're reaching a a time now
where women have gained more freedom
with their now allowed to what's inside
to match the outside yes this is the
crisis
an addition has preserved certain things
tradition has preserved a marriage but
that doesn't mean that people were
necessarily loyal that's true okay
what's true today is that men will mess
around and they'll leave because they're
not able to stick and to take care and
have leadership they will they will
that's true that's true but now the
problem is that women are now doing the
same I'm sorry but what I'll be honest
with you I'm looking at look before it
was back in the days men like let's be
honest back in days men used to be
abusing their wives all kind of stuff
yeah I'm cheating 100 cheating all that
kind of stuff today I'm sorry I've been
talking this I speak to some Simpsons
and sisters group here they're in
absolute denial yeah absolute denial
women of course
some women and lots of them are causing
havoc why not see look for example the
husband goes and gets a second wife
honestly yeah boom divorce forget
divorce Bob divorce I'm gonna accuse you
of rape I'm gonna I'm gonna accuse your
pedophilia I'm gonna get I'm not gonna
show you your kids why because he went
and got a second wife yeah in an
honorable way and the point is when we
talk about this it's an honorable way
that he's done I'm not talking about a
different story yeah the thing is here
if we look at statistics women initiate
divorce more number one number two this
is very interesting that means men are
willing to stay in the marriage look you
always go back to polynomials
sister soul I never said that victim is
the main issue one of the causes I have
to agree but where did I say polygamy is
a mission
okay
one second can I can I finish Mr
monogamous so-called man yeah listen
when did that when did I say so everyone
when did I say when did I say when did I
say polygamy is the ministry of the Wolf
the brothers that I deal with here
because we're talking about something
that is done that is permissible
I did not say that the reason why this
divorce is because polygamy how many men
get involved in polygamy not much I'm
not talking about that I'm giving one
example the point is that if a woman
statistics show and we also know from
the Quran Sunnah that the man has the
power of talaq that means the woman is
initiating the divorce more than a man
so it seems like the man is willing to
stay in the marriage and the woman is
more inclined to saying let's go our
separate ways so I'm saying can that be
a connection or cause to why divorces
are happening I must say in this this is
the woman to blame but why is there a
trend now that not Trend but statistics
show us that women are initiating it
more because yes and and now you said
that women are now cheating more yeah
okay and there's the example of for
example not every woman of course and
the example of that you said men don't
lower the Gaze when it comes to other
women women don't know the gays when it
comes to that her husband's doing this
for this person so the issue at hand I
think it's a broad topic but final
statements because I think maybe we'll
need to have a part two of this yeah
um but Gabriel So I think the 21st
century has revealed a lot to us uh
women
understanding the federal women fitter
of men yes
um what's more change or what has
changed more it's hard to to understand
but definitely both have been affected I
think what we've discovered though with
men we've kind of understood men for the
past few centuries you know men are
still you know they're capable of
violence they're capable of Wars they
you know we're very
um hot in terms of you know our
temperament and so on it's kind of known
right I mean men we've kind of were able
to assist them yeah it was simple
creatures the only thing that's
happening with men right now is that
they're even losing that they're as the
sister said they're kind of becoming
more feminine they're being emasculated
it has to deal with a lot of things well
and a woman culture yeah with women now
I think we're learning more about their
fitra and because
of the freedom that's been given yeah
um we're able to Now understand
more of what was suppressed inside right
so
um culture family certain customs and of
course definitely religion
um suppressed women
um but see it's not a bad super let me
it's not a negative suppression
necessarily right
um
I think that's going to be another
discussion but it suppressed women to
the point that we didn't know what's
inside
now with freedom
women are able to express a lot more of
what's inside which has become more
dangerous yeah if you look at um not
necessarily if you look at it
necessarily if you look at the the cam
that deal with women in the Sharia the
most strict yes a lot of people don't
understand the reason yes okay they
don't understand why it's more strict or
I mean why do women have to wear a job
why not well they have to have a woolly
a guardian why many many issues
many things actually by the way
and it is because there is the influence
women are easier to inference
one of the studies that I read
um recently that the the summary of it
the last sentence was
that
the rule of thumb when it comes to
female psychology
is that
what's inside is not necessarily going
to be reflected on the outside because
of modesty the process said right so I
think that the concept of Haya hijab and
so on is so important for women to to
literally to submit and submission is to
a next to an extent is suppressing
yourself right willingly for the sake of
Allah is to protect that fitra because
if that fitra is let loose and I read
today A beautiful statement causes have
a man are tested with their loyalty when
they're given power yes women are tested
with their loyalty when they're given
Freedom wow okay so when you look today
and again as the process and say you
will follow them inch by inch into the
whole the sub said using the Christians
he said well
um when you look and it's important to
look and compare and draw parallels
between
I mean these guys are not too far from
us bro they're just across the street
like we're not living in yes and uh not
Saudi Arabia let's say but we're not
living in like uh
I don't know uh Sudan or something right
we're here they're here next there are
neighbors we go to school with them
there are teachers there are doctors we
are very close
right so it's important to see where
they've gone yes right I would argue
that
um
when a man is given certain freedoms
there's still even the non-muslim will
have a certain limit
right because it goes against your
manhood to pass that limit even the
non-muslims are going to stop at a
certain level let's take for example
alcohol the way a man behaves with
alcohol and the way a woman behaves
without them and it's more harmful for a
Woman by the way
um that's just an example yeah it's just
an example when a man is given that
freedom and loses those senses he's
gonna stop we might fight we might
probably most like that's what's going
to happen yeah we're gonna fight
a woman's getting alcohol
it's like spring break yeah and you know
yeah
and that's exactly what they want that's
why they target the woman first Target
that and I don't want to again I know
people sometimes bro who cares about
people think about it just analyze them
because I never realized so um the
Sharia is India Islam actually is the
solution for all our problems yes and
you see that that's what comes to
promiscuity it's called submission yes
it's it's now it's a high level like we
said an alcohol effects of one more
because of anatomy the way she's created
um and even yeah it has a a big impact
it's a discussion we can carry on uh
just finish and last statements because
quickly because we've got and I just
want to talk about this part just to
conclude that's what we need insurance
that's why I wonder divorce is all the
brothers that are divorcing yes
and please just don't move on to the
next person thinking that that person
will fix you and will help you heal
that's your responsibility in front of
Allah that's your own journey to take
that person can support you why you
already started this journey and my
sisters I will I will address Masters
because that's why I'm used to address
the the divorce hitting it starts with
the Kabul and that's the two words I
always mentioned to the sisters Kabul in
a way that you accept
that it's not necessarily a punishment
like the brother was explained that very
often is the
um the guilt feeling you know it's my
fault even if the person left you very
often you will get I didn't do this send
things were your fault self
accountability is a beautiful blessing
how do you know when you've healed them
and went to where is that where's that
that line that okay I'm Healed now and I
can move on and the person is going to
support me because I believe that
who really commits to you can be part of
the healing they can help you heal to
move on no but I'm saying like this
intention has to start I have met
sisters that are moving on to marriage
they're not healed you can clearly say
angry the way they speak about the X
marriage it's all the husband's fault
it's all him and there is a lot of anger
resentment and they are really hoping
that that guy will fix whatever happened
I'm not saying he doesn't help you he
can help you and I hope you find someone
inshallah my sister Limited in the time
frame will help you but
and the second part was tobacco put your
trust in Allah that no matter what
happened to you my biggest try and I'm
going to talk on a personal level yes
became my biggest blessing open my eye
bring me back to Allah nowhere that was
I was always
like that but the blessing the you know
in the mouth
you know the use of the the success that
Allah shall give you when you accept the
test when you understand the deepness of
it and that Allah if you're looking for
love Allah is if you are worried about
the risk Allah is the reserved if you
are looking for a friend someone to
confine to Allah remember who is your
lord and always advise the first advice
I give to my sisters that goes through
that Shogun and wallahi my brothers they
are suffering and it's a very big big
test I am not on the mining Brothers
test I'm just talking about I'm from
from a female perspective though again
maybe sister
how do you know a woman healed where's
how do you where do you reach that
leveling like okay I don't think you
ever healed yeah you don't ever I think
if you're ready to move on you're ready
to move on right I really do think that
but in that time of moving on you do
need to have self reflection you do need
to take steps to have self-development
and and and advise your partner your
future partner or your spouse at the
time that you are going through it so
there's support and they're able to
handle it it's true I'm going to wrap up
but it's interesting but you know one
thing as well you said sometimes you
never heal yeah but I think maybe it is
that and team maybe I'm just talking
about 100 if I was to go really yeah
exactly exactly so that's why I think
that's why the brothers were saying that
sometimes brothers are a little bit
apprehensive because they're like okay
if the healing is not totally there but
then again like I said look it's a
discussion where look some sisters they
go videos and it makes them the better
maybe
quickly how can you access someone if
it's the person is a hill or not next
next next
no no that for the next episode you're
gonna get
we're always going to be fully healed
because there's always going to be
triggers regardless of what phase you
are in your life but it's knowing
yourself who you are and I think it's
putting yourself in a mindset is if I
was to be faced with this situation
again tomorrow how would I react what
would I do do differently do I have
enough confidence in me to know that I
can
tame the situation that I can control my
anger and my own nuffs or whatever it
may be that triggers you it's knowing
that I'm believing in itself we have to
believe in ourselves that our marriage
will work because of the hard work we've
put in we can't just go in it blindly
yes it's great that they could assist us
but if you are as I said I think you're
always healing so there's always going
to be somebody there to assist you I
mean your partner will always assist you
but you don't want to go into a marriage
and almost saying right here's my
baggage it's 50 there I've dealt 50 with
it the rest you sort of need to guide me
on because they could have their own
traumas or their own problems that
they're also healing with and it's
somewhat unfair I think if you work
together as a team then that's different
but I don't entirely think it's fair to
put it on them it's just knowing within
yourself yes I can handle this I am
closer to Allah and I believe in myself
our honorable sisters our dear brothers
inshallah until next time sisters from
the bitter trip show
um if we missed anything you are comment
in the section below tell us probably
speak about this next time inshallah and
may Allah shortcomings inshallah and
hope this is giving you some kind of
insight and some kind of Hope inshallah
until next time from the bitter truth
assalamualaikum
said whoever builds a mystery for you
will build for him a similar house in
Jannah on that day where Allah tells us
that our books will be given and every
little atom weight of God did you've
done will be there and imagine you see a
mountain and what a lucky person which
righteous person
Allah says this is for you for me yes
what did I do
you allow people to pray you built a
Masjid I never had the money to build a
master to Allah you helped you gave
towards it and Allah gives you the
reward of as if you've built it don't
let it now guys and do not delay and
share the video for extra Rewards
foreign
[Music]